semblerait que les joueurs niçois les
très mauvaises à cause du fait que
Galtier leur ai demandé de ne pas
pratiquer le jeûne un jour de match mais
c'est exactement ça
oui mais ça doit pas exister ça mais
comment ça ça doit pas exister donc il
va voir tous les catholiques et leur
demander qui fait le carême aussi
c'est le meilleur quand il est sur
Ramadan on en parle aussi de merde on en
parle de ça
c'est Christophe Galtier a demandé ça on
sait même pas quand un entraîneur qui
gère un vestiaire qui qui est
responsable
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup je ne crois
pas que les nutritionnistes nous
explique que faire un Ramadan c'est
meilleur pour la performance en même
temps il y a deux tiers de l'effectif
qui fait le ramadan est-ce que c'est un
sujet pour l'entraîneur est-ce qu'il est
en droit de demander à ses joueurs c'est
le jour du match les gars buvez un petit
peu manger un petit peu alors c'était
chaud entre vous deux hein entre Samira
après c'est une discussion comme on est
ici hein
c'était pas je m'attendais à pire non
non
tu es plus mon ami que Samir Nasri donc
forcément je t'écoute après voilà faut
voir c'est vrai que ça m'est restreint
mon ami c'est moi c'est je sais pas je
suis pas très fan euh dis-moi bon après
c'est pas qu'on se dit dis-moi c'est
quoi l'histoire
[Rires]
c'est ça en fait il y a des il y a des
gars qui disent que voilà c'est vrai que
ils disent qu'il y a des entraîneurs
Lille ils disent que c'est plus
compliqué parce que c'est plus dur de de
s'entraîner etc oui vous l'avez souligné
la Fédération n'a pas voulu de pause
pour l'hydratation il y a un entraîneur
à Nantes Antoine Kombouaré qui a dit un
joueur la semaine dernière voilà si tu
jeûnes le jour du match bah je t'écarte
et là le débat entre Philippe qui est
très talentueux et Samir Nasri c'était
en gros est-ce que c'est un sujet
aujourd'hui le ramadan dans le cadre du
football est-ce que des entraîneurs
peuvent réfléchir éventuellement à
écarter des joueurs qui feraient le
ramadan voilà en fait c'est l'affaire
Galtier Nice qui a éclaté la semaine
dernière que vous avez traité notamment
avec Daniel Riolo je suis sur ce plateau
qui pose peut-être pour la première fois
sur la table un sujet Gilles qui
jusqu'ici a longtemps été tabou enfoui
traiter en toute discrétion un peu sous
le tapis avec des petits arrangements
sauf que là bah il éclate qu'est-ce
qu'on fait au Canal Football Club bah on
traite de l'actualité et des
conséquences de ce qui relève d'un jeûne
pour origine religieuse le jeûne peut
obéir à diverses religions on les
respecte toutes profondément ces
religions le jeûne il peut obéir à une
forme d'épanouissement personnel
philosophique le jeûne il peut être le
fruit d'une mode actuellement qui
concerne le bien-être de chacun nous
c'est pas notre problème l'origine de ce
jeûne notre problème notre question et
un jour de match en sachant que en Ligue
1 cette saison 7 matchs sur 10 par
week-end se dispute en journée pas en
soirée
quand il y a dans une équipe un joueur
plusieurs joueurs une majorité de
joueurs qui ne va pas s'alimenter du
tout ni s'hydrater du tout du lever du
soleil jusqu'au coucher du soleil est-ce
que cela peut altérer éventuellement sa
performance et poser un problème à
l'entraîneur hier avec Samir Nasri avec
leur boulot avec Sidney Govou le tout
arbitré par Hervé Mathoux chacun a donné
son éclairage mais dans le respect dans
l'écoute dans l'échange explique bien
alors on fait quoi dans ces cas-là et
bien le plus souvent ça se règle par une
forme de négociation entre le club c'est
à dire un président un entraîneur et les
joueurs concernés la plupart du temps si
vous voulez tout savoir l'arrangement
idéal c'est que le jour du match le ou
les joueurs rompent le jeûne
spécifiquement ne serait-ce qu'une fois
le jour du match pour être en moins le
cas vous le savez c'est de moins en
moins le cas ou en tout cas il y a
visiblement de plus en plus de joueurs
qui ont envie d'appliquer le jeûne y
compris les jours de match d'où
l'exemple que vous donnez Gilles c'était
le week-end dernier Nantes Monaco
Antoine comboaré ne convoque pas un
joueur qu'il voulait convoquer parce que
ce joueur et ça décide de ne pas
de ne pas de ne pas rompre le jeûne
voilà Antoine Comboire est-il raciste
en prenant cette décision
personnellement je ne crois pas Gilles
moi ce qui me gêne c'est que on fait du
Ramadan un sujet oh regardez Karim
Benzema qui lui jaune il marque des
triplés exactement il y a aucune étude
scientifique aucune au monde il y en a
quand même non non il y en a aucune
sérieuse qui montre que le ramadan
pourrait altérer la performance sportive
et moi ça me gêne qu'on demande vous
avez prononcé le mot arrangement ça me
gêne que la religion qui a une pratique
intime devienne le théâtre d'arrangement
entre un club et un joueur un homme qui
a envie de faire le ramadan et qui a
envie de le faire le jour du match aussi
je vois pas pourquoi on l'empêche de le
faire et je vois pas pourquoi on
l'empêche de jouer au foot c'est
complètement une question intime et
personnelle je suis bien d'accord avec
ça sauf qu'à un moment donné dans la
spécificité de cette activité du sport
de haut niveau ça devient un engagement
professionnel aussi comment on gère ce
problème
et vous faites bien de le dire Benzema
est un très bon exemple de très bonne
gestion du Ramadan Samir Nasri nous a
éclairé là-dessus et je l'écoute avec
une grande attention ouais il y a des
joueurs qui parlent leur talents qui par
leur expérience aussi de ce genre de jeu
savent gérer parfaitement tout ça sans
qu'il n'y ait aucune conséquence sur
leur performance c'est magnifique il a
même dit Samir il y a des joueurs aussi
qui d'une certaine façon en jeûnant sont
portés par quelque chose par la foi mais
moi ça me va très bien tant que le
résultat est positif je n'ai aucun
problème mais c'est pas moi qui juge
c'est pas moi qui pose les problèmes ce
sont les entraîneurs qui gèrent ces
problématiques moi je comprends pas
qu'un entraîneur se pose la question
parce que c'est de la discrimination par
le travail leur religion c'est leur
religion ils ont le droit
en fait on a même pas besoin de le
savoir exactement c'est ça qu'il faut
pourquoi maintenant ça vient sur la
table jamais ça venait sur la table et
aujourd'hui tout le monde en parle il
l'extraction n'est pas la même malgré
tout les équipes aujourd'hui sont pas
les mêmes il y a que il y a 10 ans qu'il
y a 30 ans qu'il y a 40 ans ça on peut
on peut tous le dire non il s'agit pas
de stigmatiser de faire des quotas il y
a des il y a des équipes où il y a
beaucoup plus de joueurs musulmans et
qui font le ramadan et qui font un
amende un Ramadan strict et d'ailleurs
la religion aujourd'hui a beaucoup
d'importance dans le foot pas que le
Ramadan il y a aussi même des des
joueurs je crois brésiliens ou africains
qui sont très presque évangéliste et qui
se font le carême et qui jeûnent
exactement ça m'iront parlé également de
cet exemple
des musulmans exactement et tout c'est
je pense que c'est une vraie réalité je
pense qu'on peut pas mettre la la
poussière sous le tapis on peut pas dire
que ça n'existe pas et je pense qu'il
faut que ça se fasse dans un dans les
clubs en bonne intelligence il faut en
parler Géraldine
ça dépend mine de rien ils font des des
des des des des des des des performances
c'est tout si le mec oui exactement oui
mais si on les écarte en disant
il y a des il y a des coachs il va les
écarter si on les écarte ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'on les discrimine
ça veut dire que à cause de leur
religion leur pratique de la religion
tu dis qu'ils sont moins forts
qui font le ramadan qui sont aussi en
forme quand ils le font pas ça
il dit simplement si le joueur est moins
performant là on peut le sortir et ça
n'a rien à voir avec la la la laïcité ou
le ramadan c'est respecter la sphère
privée ils font ce qu'ils veulent les
gens qui sont écartés si tu as un joueur
si tu as un joueur toute l'année pendant
8-9 mois qui te fait des performances
des malades à l'entraînement et que
pendant le mois du Ramadan on prend
l'exemple qu'on Boiré qui voit que son
joueur est à la ramasse et qui lui dit
je peux pas je peux pas te faire jouer
dans cet état là parce que tout le monde
n'est pas Benzema c'est du on parle de
l'élite on parle du sport de très très
haut niveau moi je je suis un peu fâché
par rapport à la Ligue parce que ils
auraient pu faire des pauses comme on
fait les pauses fraîcheur pour boire un
verre d'eau et une date c'était pas non
plus la mer à boire on aurait pu on le
fait en Angleterre on le fait dans
d'autres pays nous chez nous on fait pas
ça et on se met dans des polémique parce
qu'on ne fait pas ça un moment donné si
le mec il est moins performant moi je
rejoins Comboire si tu es moins
performant je ne peux pas te mettre sur
le terrain et c'est pas pour ça
perturbe la vie du groupe la performance
pour la performance il peut aussi
considérer l'entraîneur que ça met en
danger aussi l'intégrité de ce joueur
qui ne s'est pas alimenté encore une
fois je me permettrai jamais moi de
juger de tout ça on essaye de donner un
maximum de précisions d'informations
comment se passe la préparation d'un
match pour une équipe professionnelle il
y a deux façons Raymond tu veux c'est
très bien soit il y a mise au vert
depuis la veille soit on se retrouve le
matin du match dans quel optique
pour surveiller l'alimentation elle sera
le sommeil des joueurs c'est tout il y a
des nutritionnistes il y a des
diététiciens qui travaillent pour les
clubs tout ça est très pointu
aujourd'hui dans la recherche et logique
de performance il se trouve que cette
pratique là quelle que soit son origine
va à l'encontre des habitudes
d'aujourd'hui d'où une problématique à
gérer assez simple avant les matchs à
15h les matchs exactement avant il y
avait pas exactement c'était le soir
c'est plus simple à gérer